Sấm hai tại thủ đường viên tranh lào đảng giả đức quốc hội chính phủ và mặt trại lòng xây dự đất đất đã tổ chức trọng thế biết tình cấp giả đất
Khi điểm tảm viên năm các mặt tháng tháng thành công và quốc hành phyệt năm
Đầu chi muốn thông chết bản đi, thường chực bản biệt thơ, phó chụi tính lòng đã un lại lịch sử từ khi đảng tổng sản đúc xây ra đời
Và những thị tụi đổi bật của Việt Nam cho sốt tảm viên năm qua
Những thấm lợi và thành tụi của Việt Nam là một đội đúng tò lần đổi với đảng giảnh đất
Và nhân dân các sân tập lòng trời sử dập bảo vệ và sây dự bất mức lòng
Đầu chi muốn thông chết bản đi, bệ tò lòng biết ở sâu sắc tới đảng
Nhà nước khoảng nhân dân Việt Nam anh em đã loàn sạy sự ủ hộ
Xúc lửa tò lần, quý bấu kịt hơi và hiệu quả đủ với lòng
Hẳng đến lòng sẽ làm hết sức dựng, kích thục cùng đảng
Nhà nước khoảng nhân dân Việt Nam tiếp tục dìm dữ và phát triển mỗi phó thể hủ miệnh tí dại
Việt Nam, lòng